I was sitting in my bedroom wearing my
comfiest sweatpants slamming on my
keyboard I was working on this talk
searching for the words for an
inspirational hopefully not too preachy
call for all of us to work on bridging
the divides in American culture and
politics I was writing something like
each and every one of us should be
concerned about the future of democracy
when something had caught my eye it was
a framed picture on my dresser of my
college friends of me at our graduation
this photo contains two Meghan's
- Lawrence - Kate's and my best friend
Andrea all of us grew up on the u.s.
coast after college each of us moved
back to the u.s. coast almost all of us
with a few exceptions have gone to
graduate school we're living in the Bay
Area Los Angeles Boston and New York
working in business medicine and law and
staying in touch with G with each other
by emailing around criticisms of Donald
Trump looking at this picture it became
so clear to me things like this are
where the National disconnects start we
as humans seek out others who are like
us foreclose social connection
psychologists call this Hamas aliy
meaning birds of a feather flock
together
think of your closest friends are they
similar to you and each other in race
and age did you go to the same kind of
school or do you make roughly the same
amount of money do you hold similar
views on religion and politics if so
this is completely natural we do it for
good reason
groups whose members share the same
backgrounds and vocabularies and
purposes conform quickly and provide
their members with substantial support
for minority groups bonding together
like this can be particularly valuable
because it affirms a sense of identity
and increases collective resources in
the face of oppression so some of this
is good but our society has overshot the
mark we live today with levels of
disconnectedness and division that are
not the result only a proverbial birds
of a feather flocking together but also
of insidious institution level forces
that have separated us to the point
where different Americans often see each
other as different species for one
there's a news media which allows us to
hear only one side of a story I know I
indulge this opportunity
checking the New York Times home page
multiple times per day but never
watching Fox News also we're divided by
where we live segregated along both
racial and economic lines this story is
told by the Jefferson counties
Jefferson County Mississippi is 86
percent black Jefferson County Missouri
is 95 percent white Stanford Business
School graduates beeline to New York and
San Francisco after graduation whereas
the average American lives within 18
miles of his or her mom and then there's
income inequality the result of macro
trends like globalization and automation
which have put many out of work while
the highly educated have gotten richer
I'll be honest here that this problem
has taken on a new sense of importance
and personal urgency for me after this
year's presidential election but why did
it take a presidential election for me
to get focused on such an impactful
issue this isn't just birds of a feather
flocking together this is a problem of
exposure Americans today are divided
economically culturally politically and
many of us have just passively fallen
into this pattern the forces that divide
us are so powerful and so pervasive that
we've come to see disunity as acceptable
because it's inevitable
it is not inevitable it's not inevitable
because each of us has the ability not
only to bond together with those who are
like us but also to bridge with those
who are not we can resist the forces
that pull us apart by forming personal
relationships with people who are
different from us and if we're to live
up to our ideals of democracy and
diversity we must the case for bridging
is strong everyone from the founding
fathers to today's political scientists
have argued that Americans need to form
personal relationships across
demographic lines in order to make
democracy and a heterogeneous country
work but you don't have to care about
democracy in a heterogeneous country
bridging is simply good for us as people
it rounds out our perspective and
teaches a thing that we otherwise
wouldn't learn it makes us better
business people who really know our
customers and better policymakers who
really know our constituents I believe
many of us already have the inclination
to put ourselves in someone else's shoes
but without shared experience do we
really have the ability there are three
simple ways that we can bridge first
recognize the diversity within our own
groups
remember my college friends my best
friend Andrea is a teacher in inner city
charter schools I used to be a banker so
while our friendship represents bonding
in many ways it's actually bridging
along this dimension of profession I
have learned so much from Andrea hearing
about her students and their lives
befriending her co-workers who are
career educators visiting her schools in
downtown Newark New Jersey and Hunters
Point San Francisco these experiences
have given me an empathy for the
challenges that low-income students in
urban environments face and this issue
is now extremely important to me we all
have our Andrea's who can show us
something outside of our usual routine
second let's change the way we have
conversations we miss out on so many
opportunity
needs to bridge because we try to argue
and convince rather than listen and
understand some of us here may be guilty
of this in the last political argument
that we had we my mom who's here today
and appears to be crying has another way
she is a world class chatter and we joke
in our family that if you leave her
alone in a grocery store line for even a
few minutes she'll know the life story
of the person standing next to her and
the cashier by the time you get back
this daily practice prepares her well
for more meaningful bridging
relationships
she was an effective advocate for
lessons in the foster care system and is
a fantastic psychologist for the
mentally ill individual because she
listens and empathizes and keeps an open
mind
my mom's interpersonal relationships
brought in her exposure giving her a
well tested yet ever-evolving view on
the world I aspire to that third
recognize the things in yourself that
might be different someone else and find
ways to share it my Jewish friends are
great at this they've invited me to
Shabbat dinners and Yom Kippur break
fast and these have been experiences to
share in their cultures that I've
treasured if this sounds a little
awkward or uncomfortable to you take
heart in the fact that Samantha Power's
the former US Representative to the
United Nations befriended her Russian
counterpart and frequent opponent by
taking him to theater performances in
Central Park or Knicks games in Madison
Square Garden when he was in New York
for UN meetings she can manage to do
this we should be excited to welcome
others into our world these steps may
seem small that's the point our society
can be transformed through individual
relationships these relationships are
ends in and of themselves as well as
means to more informed and compassionate
policymaking and busy
practices the sooner we start bridging
the sooner this becomes a habit even a
way of life imagine the possibilities
when each of us applies our creativity
and ingenuity towards understanding
people who look and think and live
differently from us with more of us
building bridges the prospects for a
more United future are great thank you
[Applause]
[Music]